you
a breast biopsy is usually performed to
determine if a suspicious area or lump
in your breast is cancerous in this
procedure a sample of the suspicious
tissue is removed so can be examined in
a laboratory breast biopsies involve one
of four techniques needle biopsy which
is generally done as an office procedure
stereotactic core biopsy which is done
under mammogram guidance ultrasound
guided core biopsy and surgical biopsy
performed in the operating room
if your physician can feel your lump he
or she will often perform a needle
biopsy which may take the form of assist
aspiration fine needle aspiration biopsy
or core biopsy in each procedure a
needle will be inserted into your breast
to remove fluid or to sample the tissue
if your breast lump cannot be felt and
is seen only on a mammogram or
ultrasound your physician may recommend
a stereotactic core or ultrasound guided
core biopsy for a stereotactic core
biopsy you will lie face down on a table
with your breasts visible through a hole
in the table guided by a
computer-generated mammogram of the
suspicious area your physician will
insert a hollow needle into the breast
mass and remove several small cylinders
of tissue for examination ultrasound
guided core biopsies can be performed
when your breast mass is detected on
ultrasound in this procedure your
physician will use an ultrasound probe
to locate the mass and insert a hollow
needle to remove several cores of tissue
stereotactic and ultrasound guided core
biopsies involve removing a small sample
of tissue with the needle however if a
suspicious area detected by mammogram or
ultrasound is not accessible by a core
biopsy or if your physician wants the
entire area removed he or she may
recommend a surgical biopsy
breast surgeries done in an operating
room using two techniques needle
localization and excisional biopsy
for needle localization a needle and
wire will be inserted into the breast
under mammogram or ultrasound guidance
in order to mark the location of the
suspicious area your surgeon will then
make an incision in the breast at the
site of the wire and remove the targeted
area even if your breast lump can be
felt your physician may recommend
removing the entire lump rather than
sampling it with a needle once again
your surgeon will make an incision in
the breast and remove the entire mass
surgeons will often also remove a small
amount of healthy tissue surrounding the
mass during these procedures surgical
biopsies can be done under local or
general anesthesia the type of
anesthesia should be discussed with your
surgeon since breast biopsies are done
as an outpatient you'll be able to go
home shortly after the procedure